>>George: Most people look at
education and say it's impossible.
>>Woman: The research
suggests that as early
as first grade, students
are checking out.
>>Man: If they aren't excited, or
if they don't see how it is relevant
to their life, kids are
either bored or lost.
>>George: We need a different way of
looking at what we learn, why we learn
and how do we use what we learn?
We need to teach people how to think.
>>Student: I'm going to
take a trip to Venus.
>>Steve: Twenty-five years ago, George
said, "People know education ought
to be different, but they
don't know in what way."
>>George: Saying that it needs
to be better is very, very easy.
The how is very, very hard.
So the idea of making
an archive of what works
in education seemed like a great idea.
>>Steve: We started focusing on
technology, but very quickly moved
to the broader notion, how can we
help make education better for kids?
>>Teacher: Okay, so we'll start
with your first sample now.
>>George: We started with making movies
of classrooms and processes that work,
and putting them on videotapes.
And then the internet became viable,
and we were able to take all the ideas
and put them in one place so
people had access to them.
We decided we needed to
define what education is.
What are we educating kids?
How do people actually learn?
So we've been doing that
for twenty-five years now.
>>Steve: The George Lucas
Educational Foundation has the mission
to tell the stories of
what works in education.
>>Student: Yes!
>>Salman: Edutopia has spent a
quarter century creating materials,
documenting great teachers,
talking about how you can make
those classrooms more in tune
with what actually interests students.
>>Student: Sweet, it worked.
>>Cindy: I look at Edutopia as an
experience for teachers, parents,
administrators, even for
students, to see what's possible.
>>Student: Who here have dreams
and goals they want to
achieve in their life?
>>Laura: Edutopia is like the
best staffroom we could ever have.
One of the most powerful
aspects of Edutopia is being able
to see other teachers
working in their classrooms.
>>Teacher: What was the
problem we were trying to solve?
>>George: Here's people
doing it in Texas.
Here's people doing it in North Dakota.
Here's people doing it in New York City.
You just see it, and it works.
>>Woman: Schools That Work is a series
of excellent schools across the K
through twelve spectrum that have
evidence that what they're doing works.
>>Student: I really like to read.
I would read fifty books
a day if I had the time.
>>Steve: Our most significant impact is
when we can make successful practices,
accessible to more and more
educators, so that they can try it out.
>>Man: Let's do it.
>>George: A lot of what we do
now focuses on methodology.
We're trying to introduce people
to social emotional learning,
to multidisciplinary studies,
to project based learning,
things that have been taken
for granted for so long,
that nobody ever tested them to
say, does this actually work?
>>Kristin: Our mission at Lucas
Education Research is to build
that evidence base and to think about
progressive practices that we know
in our hearts engage and inform
learning, but to really subject them
to more rigorous research trials.
>>Teacher: Does it feel
cold, does it feel hot?
>>Salman: There's a lot of talk these
days about project based learning
or inquiry, and these
aren't just nice to haves.
The key for every learner is, as soon
as they get excited about something,
they're off to the races, then it's
hard to keep the knowledge from them.
>>Teacher: We're looking to see if
the bubble is between the lines.
>>Students: It is!
>>Teacher: Nice work, people.
>>Steve: The skills kids need to
come out of high school and college
with are the skills of the problem
solver, of a creative thinker,
of a collaborator, of
a lifetime learner.
That's what our goal is, is to
help people see what's possible
and then implement it in a way
that changes what kids learn.
>>George: I don't think the work of the
foundation will ever run out of things
to do, because as we progress
and the world changes,
the educational system is going
to have to change with it,
and so we have to try to help it along.